AND WATCHING THEIR LIFE SAVINGS
EVAPORATE.
WELCOME TO "THE LEAD," I'M JAKE
TAPPER.
MOMENTS AGO THE SENATE PASSED A
BILL THAT WOULD HELP AVOID A
CATASTROPHIC RAIL STRIKE.
NOW THE LEGISLATION WHICH HAD
PASSED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HEADS TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S RESOLUTE DESK
FOR SIGNING.
JUST A FEW HOURS AGO, IT LOOKED
AS THOUGH THE AGREEMENT COULD BE
DERAILED WITH MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES DEMANDING PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR THE UNION RAIL
WORKERS.
MANU RAJU STARTS OFF OUR
COVERAGE FROM CAPITOL HILL WITH
AN INSIDE LOOK AT HOW THIS DEAL
CAME TOGETHER JUST MINUTES AGO.
>> Reporter: THE SENATE AVERTING
A DEVASTATING BLOW TO THE U.S.
ECONOMY, VOTING TO PREVENT A
RAILWAY STRIKE AFTER A TENSE
WEEK OF NEGOTIATIONS.
>> ON ONE HAND, WE DON'T WANT TO
SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY.
ON THE OTHER, WE DON'T WANT TO
TO SAY TO RAIL WORKERS, IF YOU
HAVE A HEART ATTACK OR YOU BREAK
YOUR LEG, YOU EITHER SHOW UP TO
WORK OR YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE
YOUR JOB.
>> Reporter: LAWMAKERS
RECOGNIZING THAT A STRIKE COULD
HAVE DISRUPTED FOOD SUPPLIES AND
INTENSIFIED SKY HIGH INFLATION.
TENTATIVE DEAL NOW ENFORCED BY
CONGRESS WAS BROKERED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
MAJOR RAILWAYS IN EIGHT OF 12
LABOR UNIONS.
THAT PLAN LACKS PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR WORKERS.
PROGRESSIVES ON CAPITOL HILL
DEMANDED THAT THE SENATE
GUARANTEE AT LEAST SEVEN DAYS
FOR RAIL WORKERS.
>> IT WOULD BE AN ABSOLUTE
OUTRAGE IF THESE WORKERS DO NOT
GET AT LEAST SEVEN DAYS SICK
LEAVE.
>> THIS IS A SMALL NUMBER OF
DOLLARS TO THEIR BOTTOM LINE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR WORKERS THE
WAY THEY SHOULD.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
DEFENDED THE DEAL AT THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY WHEN QUESTIONED ON
PAID SICK LEAVE.
>> I MADE IT REALLY CLEAR IS
WHAT WAS NEGOTIATED WAS SO MUCH
BETTER THAN ANYTHING THEY HAD.
>> Reporter: THE AMENDMENT TO
MANDATE SICK LEAVE FELL EIGHT
VOTES SHY OF THE 60 NEEDED FOR
PASSAGE.
OPPOSITION FROM MOST REPUBLICANS
WHO SAY THAT CONGRESS SHOULD NOT
DICTATE THE TERMS OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
MODERATE DEMOCRAT JOE MANCHIN
AGREED.
>> CONCERNED ABOUT US JUMPING
INTO THAT WHEN YOU HAVE EIGHT
UNIONS WHO HAVE AGREED TO THE
PACKAGE THEY NEGOTIATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
I'M VERY RELUCTANT FOR US TO
JUMP IN AND SET A PRECEDENT.
>> Reporter: BEHIND THE SCENES,
THE LOBBYING CAMPAIGN
INTENSIFIED.
LABOR SECRETARY MARTY WALSH,
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG JOINING A PRIVATE
LUNCHEON WITH DEMOCRATS AND
DEMANDING ACTION.
>> THE SENATE CANNOT LEAVE UNTIL
WE GET THE JOBS DONE.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN SKEPTICAL, THE PLAN WINNING
THE SUPPORT OF GOP MITCH
McCONNELL, AND KEVIN McCARTHY
OPPOSED THE DEAL WHEN IT PASSED
THE HOUSE ON WEDNESDAY.
THE VOTE WAS A BIPARTISAN ONE IN
THE SENATE THAT JUST CLOSED
MINUTES AGO.
THE VOTE WAS 80-15.
80 VOTING YES, 15 VOTING AGAINST
US IT.
FIVE NO VOTES WERE DEMOCRATS.
TEN WERE REPUBLICANS.
SENATOR RAND PAUL, AFTER A WEEK
OF BACK AND FORTH, A BIPARTISAN
VOTE IN THE SENATE GETS --
ESSENTIALLY MOVES FORWARD ON
THIS TENTATIVE AGREEMENT WITHOUT
THE SICK LEAVE.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
THE BILL JUST PASSED THE SENATE
DESPITE OBJECTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF BOTH PARTIES WHO WANTED PAID
SICK LEAVE TO BE INCLUDED.
WHY ARE YOU OKAY PASSING A DEAL
THAT DOES NOT GUARANTEE PAID
SICK LEAVE FOR THESE UNION
WORKERS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE DEAL IS THAT A RAIL SHUT
DOWN IS BEING AVOIDED.
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICAN WORKERS LAID OFF,
ENERGY PRICES SHOOTING UP ONCE
REFINERIES WERE UNABLE TO
CONTINUE OPERATING.
ISSUES GETTING CHLORINE TO WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS.
AUTO INDUSTRY FACTORIES GETTING
SHUT DOWN WITHIN HOURS, IF NOT
DAYS OF THAT HAPPENING.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO AVOID
IS A MAJOR BLOW TO WORKERS,
FARMS, FAMILIES ACROSS COUNTRY.
NOT EVERYBODY GOT WHAT THEY
WANTED IN THIS DEAL, BUT WHAT
WAS ENACTED IS SOMETHING THAT
MIRRORS WHAT WAS REACHED IN THE
TENTATIVE AGREEMENT AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE BETWEEN UNION
LEADERS AND RAILROAD COMPANIES.
WHAT THAT INCLUDES IS A 24% PAY
INCREASE FOR RAILROAD WORKERS.
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
DESERVE TO BE PAID WELL, ON
AVERAGE, $100,000 OR SO IN PAY.
IT INCLUDES ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR
HEALTH CARE, AN ADDITIONAL DAY
OF PAID PERSONAL LEAVE, BUT,
AGAIN, NOT A PERFECT DEAL.
AND EVERY SIDE HAD TO GIVE IN
SOMETHING IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
TO REACH THAT DEAL.
I THINK THERE'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION IN THIS COUNTRY
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE SURE WORKERS
IN THIS SECTOR AND EVERY SECTOR
GET THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
RIGHT NOW, WHAT YOU HAVE IS A
DEAL IMPROVING PAY AND WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR AMERICAN RAILROAD
WORKERS AND CRUCIALLY AVOIDING A
SHUT DOWN THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING TO THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION, THE SHUT
DOWN WOULD HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING
TO THE AMERICAN ECONOMY, AND I
THINK EVERYBODY OUT THERE IS
GLAD THAT IT HAS BEEN AVOIDED.
BUT, THE QUESTION IS, THESE RAIL
LINES, THEY'RE MAKING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, PROFITS ARE UP FOR
ALL OF THEM.
QUITE A LOT IN SOME CASES.
YOU AND I HAVE PAID SICK LEAVE.
MY CREW HAS PAID SICK LEAVE.
WHY DON'T THESE RAILWAY WORKERS
DESERVE PAID SICK LEAVE?
>> LET ME REMIND YOU, THE
POSITION OF OUR ADMINISTRATION
IS THAT EVERY AMERICAN WORKER
OUGHT TO HAVE PAID LEAVE,
WHETHER YOU'RE A RAILROAD
WORKER, A JOURNALIST, A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE, OR WHETHER
YOU WORK AT BURGER KING.
WE BELIEVE EVERY AMERICAN
WORKER, EVERY FULL-TIME AMERICAN
WORKER OUGHT TO HAVE PAID LEAVE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PROPOSED THAT,
HAS ADVANCED THAT IN PROPOSED
LEGISLATION, AND SO FAR IT HAS
BEEN UNABLE TO GET PAST WHAT HAS
BEEN UNIFIED SENATE REPUBLICAN
OPPOSITION.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PRESS FOR THAT.
NOT JUST PICKING AND CHOOSING
ONE SECTOR OVER ANOTHER, BUT
BASED ON THE BASIC IDEA THAT
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN WORKERS
OUGHT TO HAVE PAID LEAVE, JUST
LIKE YOU HAVE IN PRETTY MUCH
EVERY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
RIGHT NOW, A TENTATIVE AGREEMENT
REACHED AT THE BARGAINING TABLE
BETWEEN UNION LEADERS AND
COMPANIES CONTAINS PROVISIONS
LIKE THE PAY RAISE AND
IMPROVEMENTS.
>> I GET IT, BUT SAYING THAT
THEY OUGHT TO HAVE PAID SICK
LEAVE AND THEN GETTING IN THERE
AND SAYING TO THE WARREN
BUFFET'S OF THE WORLD, GIVE
THESE GUYS PAID SICK LEAVE OR
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO MAKE
YOU GUYS OUT TO BE THE BAD GUYS
AND YOU'LL BE FORCED TO BLINK
AFTER YOUR REPUTATIONS TAKE A
NUMBER OF HITS, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT MATTER.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF
UNION WORKERS WHO FEEL LIKE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS LET HIM
DOWN.
HE TOLD CNN QUOTE, HERE WE HAVE
SOMEONE WHO HAS TOUTED HIMSELF
AS THE MOST LABOR FRIENDLY
PRESIDENT FOR MANY DECADES AND
BASICALLY JUST BETRAYED US.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
ANYMORE, THEY'RE FEEDING
CORPORATE GREED, UNQUOTE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO GABE
CHRISTIANSON?
>> IF YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY DIFFERENCE, YOU SHOULD LOOK
AT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
PRESIDENT WHO HAS ADVANCED GOOD
PAYING JOBS, WHO HAS MADE SURE
THE NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD IS ABLE TO DO ITS JOB, WHO
HAS PUT IN THE FIRST CARD
CARRYING UNION MEMBER TO BE
LABOR SECRETARY IN A GENERATION,
WHO HAS UPHELD EVERYTHING FROM
WAGES TO WORKING CONDITIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT UNIONS CAN THRIVE
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES STRONGLY IN
AMERICAN UNIONS, IN ORGANIZED
LABOR, AND IS PROUD TO BE THE
MOST ACTIVELY PRO UNION
PRESIDENT IN A GENERATION.
AGAIN, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
EVERYBODY GOT EVERYTHING THAT
THEY WANTED.
WE NEED TO HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE LABOR
MODELS AND THE BUSINESS
PRACTICES OF TRANSPORTATION
COMPANIES IN THIS COUNTRY, AND I
THINK THAT CONVERSATION IS GOING
TO CONTINUE, AND WILL REACH A
NEW PHASE AS SOON AS THE INK IS
DRY ON THIS BILL.
IN THE MEANTIME, WHAT YOU HAVE
IS A TENTATIVE AGREEMENT THAT
WAS REACHED BY UNION LEADERS AND
COMPANY LEADERS AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE, AND THERE
SIMPLY WERE NOT VOTES.
AS WE SAW, NOT THE VOTES IN THE
SENATE FOR SURE TO GO IN AND
CHANGE THE TERMS OF WHAT WAS
REACHED AT THAT TABLE, AND THIS
IS NOT A SITUATION WHERE YOU CAN
PLAY AROUND, WHERE YOU CAN ALLOW
THINGS TO COME TO THE BRINK,
EVEN BEFORE THE DATE OF A
POTENTIAL SHUT DOWN.
SEVERAL DAYS BEFORE THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE SEEN SHIPMENTS BEGIN
TO WIND DOWN, HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS, POTENTIALLY INCLUDING
CHLORINE FOR WATER TREATMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY, NOT ABLE TO GET TO
WHERE IT NEEDED TO GO.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE WE
COULDN'T ALLOW BRINKSMANSHIP TO
OVERRIDE THE ECONOMIC AND
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THIS
COUNTRY, BUT WE ARE FAR FROM
DONE AS AN ADMINISTRATION, DOING
OUR CONTINUED WORK TO CREATE
GOOD PAYING JOBS, TO SUPPORT
UNION JOBS, AND AGAIN,
CONTINUING TO PRESS THE CASE FOR
PAID LEAVE FOR EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN IN EVERY SINGLE JOB IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO PRESS
THE CASE IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING
TO ACTUALLY GO TO THESE
BILLIONAIRES AND SAY HOW ON
EARTH CAN YOU SLEEP AT NIGHT,
NOT LETTING YOUR RAILWAY WORKERS
HAVE PAID SICK LEAVE, I MEAN,
THAT'S NOT AN EXTRAVAGANT
BENEFIT, PAID SICK LEAVE, YOU
GET SICK, YOU GET TO TAKE A FEW
DAYS OFF.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT.
SO I GUESS THESE LOFTY
ASPIRATIONS ARE ONE THING, BUT I
DIDN'T HEAR ANY LANGUAGE COMING
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION SAYING
THESE RAIL COMPANIES NEED TO GET
SERIOUS ABOUT OFFERING BASIC,
BASIC BENEFITS LIKE PAID SICK
LEAVE.
I DIDN'T HEAR THAT, SO I
UNDERSTAND WHERE GABE
CHRISTIANSON IS COMING FROM.
>> WELL, AGAIN, WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTED WAS
WHAT THE UNION LEADERS AND THE
COMPANY LEADERS AGREED TO.
AND DID NOT INSERT CHANGES INTO
THE AGREEMENT BECAUSE THAT WOULD
HAVE LIKELY ADDED TIME AND
COMPLICATION TO A PROCESS THAT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN US OFF THE
CLIFF ECONOMICALLY.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR, VERY
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
HAVE COME FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION ADVANCING PAID
LEAVE, AND IF FRIENDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE WOULD
WORK WITH US, WE COULD HAVE HAD
THAT.
WE COULD HAVE THAT IN THE
FUTURE, AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON.
IN THE MEANTIME, WHAT WE HAVE
NOW IS MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
CAN BREATHE A SIGH OF RELIEF
KNOWING THAT EVERYTHING FROM
BABY FORMULA TO MILK TO
PETROLEUM PRODUCTS THAT AFFECT
THE PRICE OF GASOLINE TO
TREATMENT MATERIALS FOR WATER TO
ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS WE COUNT
ON WILL CONTINUE MOVING AND THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO GET THEM
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO NOT ONLY
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL DAY OF PAID
PERSONAL LEAVE PER THE AGREEMENT
THAT WAS REACHED BUT ALSO A 24%
PAY INCREASE.
>> YEAH, OBVIOUSLY NOT EVERY
LABOR LEADER WAS ON BOARD WITH
THAT PLA